-Theo, we have to get into it.
I want to get into "White Lotus"
and I have questions
about you and you personally
and all that stuff.
And don't worry --
-Very personal.
-Yeah, very personal.
Yeah. Yeah, and that one scene.
But anyway...
It just -- Yeah, I really want
to know about that or --
Yeah, but a lot
of people out there.
But let's first --
You got to see Kevin Bacon.
-Oh, Jesus, Kevin Bacon.
-He's unbelievable, right?
Talented guy.
-My wife worked with him
years ago.
-On what show?
-They know each other.
It's called "The Following."
-Oh, yeah.
-It's about serial killers.
-Of course, yeah.
-Sexy serial killers.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
But I haven't met him before.
What a [bleep] legend.
-Yeah, he is -- Yeah.
He can do everything.
He can sing, act.
I heard you were in a band.
-I was in lots of
terrible bands. Yeah.
-Please, let's talk about that.
I love embarrassing my guests.
What was the first
embarrassing band you were in?
-The first band,
I was at university.
We called ourselves Barracuda,
like the fish.
-Yeah.
-And my lasting memory of it --
Because we kind of did it
in people's living rooms.
We were that low-key.
My lasting memory of it
was someone
throwing a bottle of urine
at me and being like...
-Wait. Why was someone carrying
a bottle of urine in a house?
-Because, you know, we were 20,
and it was a terrible house.
-Yeah, that's what kids do.
Yeah.
-Yeah, they pee in bottles,
spit in each other's mouths.
-Yeah. Wow.
Were you a punk band?
-No, we were like a --
We were a folk band
for some strange reason.
-What are you talking about?
Someone threw a bottle of urine
at a folk band?
-Basically, we would do these
gigs and we would turn up.
We would have a cello
and, like, you know,
very pretentious stuff.
And people would be vomiting
and, like, doing ecstasy
in front of us.
-Oh, my God.
-It was the wrong crowd,
basically.
-I think so. A bad gig.
Yeah, oh, my gosh.
Well, now you're a superstar.
Come on.
-Eh, I get it, I get it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's Theo James.
Theo James, please, let's talk
about "The White Lotus,"
because the scene that
everyone is talking about is --
-Which scene is that?
-Well, I'm sure this is the
first time you've heard of this,
but you do the nude scene
in the first episode.
-Oh, the "pee-pee scene."
-Is that what you call it?
-No, that's what they call it.
-Yeah, but wow!
-Everyone on set.
-Dude, people thought it was
the Loch Ness Monster.
They didn't know
what was happening.
What in the -- what in the --
Good for you, by the way.
Oh, my God.
-No.
-And, please, stay seated.
I don't want
you getting exhausted.
I don't want you getting tired
leaving or standing up, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Just stay in your chair.
We'll wheel you out of here.
Yeah.
Whoo! Oh, my gosh.
-I can't breathe sometimes
because the weight of it.
♪♪
Yeah.
-So, when that scene comes up,
do you go, "Oh, I got this.
Yeah."
-Yeah, I was just like,
"Jesus Christ, I'm up for it."
No, the truth of it was --
So, you know,
you go into these things
and you have a conversation
with the director
and the producers, and they go,
"Okay, for this,
we're going to use a prosthetic.
We're going to use something."
And you say,
"Okay, that sounds good."
And they say --
-So it is a prosthetic.
-Yeah, it's a
pee-pee prosthetic.
-Oh, thank goodness. Wow!
-It's a -- Yeah, exactly.
-That makes so many men
feel so good right now.
-Right, exactly.
So, but I'll tell you
the story, because --
So, you know,
you have a conversation.
And the lovely Rebecca, who was
the make-up designer, comes up.
And she's like, "You know,
this is what they want to do.
But, obviously,
we want to have some input."
So, I said, "Honestly, I just
want it not to be distracting."
He needs to be regular Joe,
because the scene's about --
You know, it's not about
the pee-pee.
It's about power play in sex.
It's about, you know, whether he
did it deliberately
or whether it was an accident
and what that means
and all that kind of stuff.
And she says, "I got you.
Yeah, I got you.
Regular Joe."
-Regular Joe.
-Yeah. I'm like, "Okay, cool."
So, we get to set,
and she's got, like,
a hammer or something.
I mean, it's bigger than that.
It's like she stole it off
a donkey in the field.
I mean, the thing is ginormous.
And me and the director,
Mike White,
are sitting there going,
"That's average, is it?"
We're, like, calling
our respective partners
being like, "I'm so sorry."
-Yeah. So, okay, good.
-Yeah, so it was 9 inches
flaccid and about 4 inches wide.
We were like,
"What the hell is that?!"
Funny enough,
your producer said,
"So, what did you do with it?
Have you still got it?"
I was like,
"No, I don't have it."
-Did you save it?
No, yeah, you don't save it.
-Like, sleeping with it.
-Sleep next to it.
There's not much we can say
about the show so much,
because I don't want to
spoil anything.
-True.
-There's two episodes left.
Is everyone trying to
get you to say,
"Hey, who was murdered,
and who murdered who?"
-Yeah. And I can
tell you tonight,
the person that
was murdered was...
No, joke.
But, yeah, everyone is trying,
including --
I was -- You know, I came
this morning on the plane,
and I was at the urinal.
And someone was like,
"Great show, man."
I was like, "Okay. Thanks."
He was like, "You going to give
me some tips at the end?"
I was like,
"I'm not exactly sure
what that means here
in the urinal."
-Yeah, you're in the urinal.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, you were going to
the bathroom.
-So, we took a photo together,
had a small kiss.
-He wanted a photo, too?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Well, I guess you can't
say no twice, right?
You go, "Yeah,
I can't give you the spoiler,
but, yeah,
let's do a selfie, sure."
He's like, "Hey, can you get
your co-star in there, too?"
-Yeah. "Mr. Snake."
[ Cymbal crash ]
-I was watching.
I go, "Man, that is such a
tricky role to play."
But every character is
so tricky.
So well-drawn, so well-done,
so well-acted.
Jennifer Coolidge,
obviously, we love.
Aubrey Plaza
is off the charts in this.
-Yeah, she's great.
-She's hit a grand slam.
And you -- You and Aubrey --
Oh, my God.
Dude, I'm just loving it.
The whole cast is great.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Theo James
in "The White Lotus."
Take a look.
-Cheers!
-To volcanoes
and all the threesomes
of past and present and future.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like you sow your oats
when you're young,
and then you just --
you know, you get it
out of your system.
-I don't know.
Not sure it works like that.
-I know, but that's the idea.
-Well, it's kind of like food,
you know?
You know, gorge yourself until
you're sick,
you swear you'll
never eat another bite,
and then, a few days later,
you're hungry again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Theo James!
Check out the second installment
of "The White Lotus"
Sundays on HBO and HBO Max.